the Joe Rogan experience he's so thick
yeah yeah he's broad man I remember when
Dustin was making 145 mm-hmm crazy he
looks like he's having a hard time
making 55 now but look man the
difference between him at 45 and 55 it's
pretty significant so with Dustin like I
I'm kind of biased because he's ones
friends right
but um you see how max max dominated a
lot of guys at 45 and then all that you
know we talked about Max is like now he
now he's the greatest now he's the
greatest at 145 he may he may be the
goat he may be greater than Joe say
although like that's an argument people
can make well he beat him twice and
although he beat him later in his career
right Josie's not 50 years old he was in
this early third yeah and he was still
he was still the number one guy he was
still dominating everybody else meeting
everybody else but like the way max beat
those guys beat Ortega beat Joe say
twice um and then Dustin's having these
tough fights he's he's fighting these
same guys he's fighting gage he's
fighting Eddie he's winning them he's
convincingly winning them but um when he
fights max like max that the fight is
Dustin's fight is the same fight that he
had with gauging he's the same as far as
competitiveness right max was still in
there but Dustin wins these but like I
just like this is where my bias kicks in
I'm like give that man some credit man
like I I mean I know everybody loves
Dustin I mean not everybody but people
loved us and they appreciate the way you
fight say appreciate his style but I'm
like man he's he's taken out like
champions mmm taking out Champions Gate
she was a champion was in World Series
but he's a champion
you don't took out Eddie champion you
know you know max champion he's like all
these guys he's beating sérgio pet I
mean Andre Anthony Pettis champion you
know just champion after champ he also
rises to the occasion he fought better
against max and any other party ever
fought his career that's the thing about
him though like he just he's like he's
like the cream you know he's he rises
that that's that's that's why that's why
his nickname is a diamond
you know what do you think happens when
he fights could be yeah this this is the
one that's the fight like so far like
that's I mean khabib is the guy Kabhi
was definitely the guy and now I was
talking to him about it I so i'm just i
started a new podcast i am i sup fam sup
fam
sup fam with you Edward yeah no I just
just releases to date on my YouTube just
started today yeah well just released
the first episode oh all right um and
Dustin's my first guess
oh so I was out there with him last week
we're just hanging out we talked about
some of that but like what do I think
happens this is a tough fight this like
it's the toughest fight everybody's
going to get right um
I absolutely understand and agree that
kabhi should be going in as the favorite
right um I want of course I want Dustin
to win this fight the every round starts
on the feet Dustin's got to make smart
moves every single time because when
khabib takes him down it's it's oh well
it's virtually impossible to get back to
your feet right and that's where could
be he was gonna want this fight to
happen Dustin's gonna have his
opportunities but like is he going to be
able to stop that wrestling consistently
enough to make this fight happen where
it's best for him and that's the hardest
thing he's got a good training camp he's
got really good people there with him
he's got Mike Brown there you know who I
want to get with him Greg Google espy I
want Gregory Gillespie to get with
Dustin and just get on top in for the
next two months just feel that high
level rustling yeah smashing pressure
just that pressure pressure pressure and
get comfortable working out of it
working under there protecting yourself
doing that would he be interested in I
mean he might fight him down the road
though it's possible yeah right um but
like Tyrone and Robbie train together a
long time ago that's true yeah I mean
that's how you get better yeah like it's
it's it's one of those things where it's
like you you got to sometimes you got to
trade with a potential rival or you know
not an enemy bro but like iron sharpens
iron yo and
sometimes you got it you have to go with
somebody that's a possible matchup in
the future especially if you're going to
fight a guy who has that same style and
did I think you nailed it - because
Gregor Gillespie is probably when you
get past could be the scariest wrestler
in the division yeah I mean here's a guy
that gets on top of people and just
smashes him and he's relentless with his
with his wrestling also he's a guy who's
not gonna get tired he's gonna put that
pressure and he's gonna come forward and
once he gets a hold of you if you don't
use perfect technique to escape and get
that distance back he's just gonna chain
wrestle and chain wrestle there's
there's no there's no stopping until
you're down until he scores his -
there's that the takedown still
happening yeah he's got some [ __ ]
relentless strength and conditioning
sessions - that he puts on his Instagram
you watching you go oh this is why this
guy doesn't get tired [ __ ] that guy
doesn't get tired cuz he's he's obsessed
yeah I come he he runs he wants like
five minute miles was it real like he'll
won like six of them straight first like
he like he will he will one like you'll
run eight miles and he'll keep them all
under six minutes so he'll run six miles
in a half an hour yeah he can do that
he's crazy wow that's crazy that's like
that's high-level marathon Hayes right
yeah like you people don't people don't
know some of the things about about
these guys like like there was a point
where training with these guys I was
just like alright I'm too old to be
doing that like I can't I just can't
keep up with that you know I mean
[Applause]